you know it really is amazing how many
stars are expecting right now but can we
just say that nobody in the free world
does pregnancy like Jessica Simpson I
mean look at this woman she's a goddess
and nothing is a few personal Jessica's
like hey everybody what should I do
about my swollen feet and guess what she
found somehow but it appears just needed
no help to pick a baby named birdie
that's what jess is calling her little
girl on the way the 38 year old mama
sort of made the announcement when she
posted pics from her baby shower that
happened Saturday you can see it there
the sign birdies nest birdie was
actually the entire theme origami birds
were given to guests who posted can't
wait to meet little birdie the menu said
a little birdie told me suck your beaks
with a dine on JFC Jessica's Fried
Chicken McDon scens burgers and fries
and gold sprinkled doughnuts
I crave with a girl I just want like
pop-tarts and cinnamon rolls and
cinnamon gummi bears
so why birdie a source tells et the
moniker runs in the family and Pope
Jessica just loved the name and thought
it was so sweet
Busy Philipps daughter is also called
birdy and it was Sandra Bullock's
character named in hope floats - ain't
birdy Calvin it's pretty and wonder how
Jessica prepared for her baby bash the
day before she posted this shot of her
getting cupping as a remedy for her
swollen feet and it works because she
captioned the after shot as skank holes
skinny ankles Friday night Jessica had a
date night with husband Eric and proving
she has a sense of humor about her
pregnancy bod she posted this epic 10
year challenge Jessica how's it feel to
have won a few years challenge
[Applause]
[Music]